I have hands...
Heh, I'll just die! I'll keel over and die!
[laughs] That'll be great.
I'm not here, I'm a sleepy baby!
Boo hoo, my nightmares are bad but I'm sleeping!
Oop, that's not- hm-hm-hm-hmm!
No no no no!
You probably don't care if I have my light on or off it's-
This is curtains, you can't see- [yells] you're still there.
Uh oh... OHHHHHH!
I'm fubbernucked anyway so bring it on!
[jumpscare]
[yelps]
Turn off the curtains. You gotta turn off the curtains for Freddy.
That's how that works and that's how logic is.
Okay, alright, m-m-m-moaning!
Don't kill me, please.
[loud jumpscare]
Fucking ughrrr!
[jumpscare]
[yells]
[banging on door]
Okay hi, you actually coming in-? OOH!
Okay good job Bonnie, go FUUUUMP yourself.
Right? Ooh that's- that's the opposite of good!
[sings] I'm sleeping, I'm sleeping! Can't you hear me snoooring?
[child screams in the game] Well that's interesting in my house where I don't think I have any other brothers or sisters that could scream at that pitch.
[sings softly] Close the door, go away.
[normal voice] I need to get up right now URGH!
Oh it is... oh hi, hello.
Oh my god (x4)
That's terrifying, holy fucking shit.
[yells] YESSSSSS!
[yells more] YESSS!
Yeah this is weird, alright.
I don't know what it means by "hide", there's nowhere to hide here!
It's a big empty room, where am I gonna go?
Am I gonna slide into the bookshelf?
Am I gonna slip under the couch?
File myself away under "Fubbernucked"?
Boy oh boy, oh bo- oh boy!
Oh bo- oh boned. Oh boned I am.
Oh say can you see how boned I am in my butt.
[sings] Then go over to the other side.
Ohhh hi!
Freddy boy!
Freddy boyyy!
Freddy boy, how you doin' Freddy boy?
Bonnie might be coming down and Bonnie might bash open those doors and bash in my skull with her big Bonnie bonnigan. [gasps]
Hi...
Oh that's baaad!
[jumpscare]
Ow...
Look. Imma risk a look.
Ooh that's a bad look!
[yells]
That's not a good sound.
Ohh...
[loud jumpscare]
[yells]
Okay, am I dead? I'm not dead (x4).
That's right, you just scare me.
[sings] But that's okayy.
[sings] Don't listen to the noises of the night.
AGHHH!
I'm fucked!
Oh they're- oh I'm fucked, I'm fucked, I'm fucked!
[jumpscare]
[yells]
Fuckleduckle.
What am I doing? Wait- woah! (x4).
That's- HEY!
The fuck is that?
Oh my god, I don't know what's happening.
But I don't like it.
It's 5AM and I'm too close to this to be bullshitted!
Man, as soon as Freddy goes I'm diving in that corner and [unintelligible].
Freddy go go go, go Freddy, go Freddy, go Freddy go!
G-go Freddy go!
Yes!!
[yells]
What the fuck?! (x3)
What the fuck? (x3) Someone's at my window!
Get up! (x4)
Hi, are you-? Please don't be Foxy.
Oh, get that! Okay.
I have a funny feeling... [screams] The wrong feeling!!
Noo!
Oh that's not good, that's the opposite of good.
There's... I- did I bug it by getting a two-fer?
No, there! Off to the left!
Why are you there again?!
[screams]
Was that a two-fer or was that a one-off?
[jumpscare]
[screams loudly]
Okay Foxy, no no no!
Foxy no no!
[jumpscare]
[yells]
I didn't think I actually did that, I was so concentrated!
I was so flocused!
Ah good yes, you put me in the shitty toilet!
Oh good, thank you for that, why is this in MY basement?
Hello?
Oooh hi!
Hello!
Who are you?
Ooooh!
[very loud jumpscare]
[yells] Fucking god damnit.
Shitty dicky balls.
Okay, no? Alright then.
[very loud jumpscare]
[yells] I didn't seee you!
Fuck man, I just got a ruhhhh!
My poor heart can't took that!
Fah-ook yook!
This seems- okay where am I now?
Oh boy oh boy, this is pipey.
I love pipe!
Good thing you got thurplus of pipe because that's my favorite thing to have when I'm in the dark basement
and fearing for my LIFE!
No way, no how. There's no way in hell that I would ever look back
because if I were to look back, and when there's a door right in front of me...
Okay I looked back! You don't know what that did but I did it!
[running footsteps approach]
[screams]
[loud jumpscare]
I shouldn't have looked back...
I got this, I got this. I know what to do, I know what to do.
Oh like a butterfly, like a butterFLYYY!
Holy shit, I saw that movement!
Oh, no door!
Oh we're in no-door land!
Oh no door, no door!
Hold the door no-door, we ain't going nowhere hodor!
"Flash him 12 times to beat"
What? Whaaat?
What does that even mean; I gotta flash him?
I gotta give him the ol' 'nip show'?
Huh?
The fuckin- I can't MOVE!!
I don't know how to move!
[screeches] Oh, hi.
[loud jumpscare]
Who's there? Oh no RUN!!
No, oh you were- it was right!
I was correct, but I didn't do it right!
Oh boy [screams]
[loud jumpscare]
I just- I just shocked him, he didn't go back!
Oh, where'd he go? Oh he's here isn't he.
Oh hey, woah hey!
Wh-heyyy!]
Oh my god! (x5)
If I look away, do you just go away?
Hi!
Aaaayyyy!
[jumpscare]
Oh, that's my head
in your mouth. I am dead.